you know what is one of my favorite
things in the world to do is even though
I am a positive positive guy positive
friendly fella I also love
on stuff food on
things I shouldn't have stopped it
and everybody was like hello brother I
brought my mom you don't want that no I
love shooting on things like like even
if it doesn't make any sense it's just
fun to be like horses you know need half
horses goddamn stretched out dogs with
their long faces and their bone legs for
me it's fun get your pulse go and it's a
fun time but listen to this I am always
shocked at how some of the things that I
used to hate are now some of the things
I love the most like for example when I
was a kid I thought girls rinky now I
that's that's a ridiculous way to start
this here's my point give things a
chance and I say even if you don't like
it take a break then give it a second
chance you can shut the door on
something that's fine but I say don't
lock it behind you like I made fun of
Game of Thrones everybody loves Game of
Thrones but I've on Game of Thrones
before on this show on Conan and I did
it because when it started everybody
loved it and went crazy and I felt left
out cuz I wasn't watching it so just
walked around like the excluded kid like
yeah there's a map sack on a broom Game
of Thrones
suck a dick leg shilling kicking a can
but you know what I'm watching now
because it's great Game of Thrones yeah
it turns out I love Game of Thrones and
Dinklage and the way they kill off my
favorite main characters but I'm not
embarrassed that I changed my mind in
fact I'm proud of myself I closed the
door but I didn't lock it hey it's the
same with food too never shut off to a
food like you know how old I was the
first time I had an egg my first egg
dish 24 that's right I was married
before I tried my first frittata why
because growing up in my house the word
egg was a swear because me and my older
brother we had like a misunderstanding
of how chickens work and we thought eggs
came out of their butts gross but when I
was 24 I was with my wife and I got some
eggs
that was a big moment for me that's
right first I tried lifelong commitment
then I tried a flat omelet in that order
one of them worked hint wasn't the
marriage that didn't go over easy
truth be told I'm back on not eating
eggs because it turns out they don't
come from a chicken's butt they come
from a hole that is both its butt and
its vagina so worse but I'm not gonna
lock the door even this time check back
with me in two years maybe I'll be back
to eating those tasty little orbs from
the chicken ass puss